uh captain did you know direct secret
project was a blarg Ian snaggle beast
insomniac games new ratchet and clank is
the best of both worlds and that it
retails the duo's origin story for
serious newcomers but also has a ton of
new content for old fans developers are
literally calling it a game based on a
movie based on a game and I'm totally
okay with this Ratchet and Clank set to
launch in spring 2016 is a retelling of
the original 2002 PlayStation 2 game but
not quite the new game work closely
follows the plot of the Ratchet and
Clank movie which will be released in
April the film depicts a more detailed
colorful version of how ratchet met
Clank and started their adventures so
it's the film's narrative that serves as
the basis for the 2016 ratchet and clank
game I hope that makes sense but just go
with it I promise it's awesome when Sony
announced it was reimagining the first
ratchet and clank I bet you thought it
meant an HD remaster that's absolutely
not the case the game may feature
familiar areas from the first game but
it's nothing like its predecessor for
one thing new areas have been added new
levels whole new planets new bosses just
a bunch of new stuff borrowed from the
world depicted in the film the world
feels richer more lived-in than the
original game not to say the original
wasn't great in and of itself but this
time around we're getting a deeper look
at the universe insomniac has created
but this isn't a movie tie-in game let
that be clear it's just a more vivid
involved way for players to get to know
ratchet and clank perhaps the best thing
about the ratchet and clank redo is its
weapons and handling in addition to a
handful of brand new weapons like the
pixel Iser insomniac games has brought
weapons from the future series that is
the more recent ratchet and clank titles
and added them back into the duo's past
this includes the combustor and
warmonger as well as everyone's favorite
enemy distracting tool the groovey tron
and before you can ask yes you can make
anyone any enemy regular grunt or boss
and every NPC dance what better way to
really push the limits of your new gear
then with crafting ratchet and clank
features the weapon upgrade system from
2013 title into the nexus that will
allow players to unlock some seriously
powerful tool abilities
players can collect materials to add to
and beef up their weapons piling some
light RPG elements to Ratchet and Clank
snoo look so it's like playing the first
Ratchet and Clank with more stuff to do
with the smooth sleek handling of the
more recent titles in the series it's a
perfect blend of old and new oh and
they're strafing you can strafe now
insomniac games says they put a lot of
work into making the ratchet and clank
reimagining an entirely new experience
and from what we've seen that statements
holding up it feels both familiar and
surprising an entirely new experience
from an older comforting classic
you